Office Unemployment has been below four
percent for almost a year and a half the
last time our nation had such a long
stretch of low unemployment was in the
1960s
the share of working age Americans in
the workforce is also at its highest
level in 16 years the president's
leadership to avert default means we
will continue to deliver good jobs for
the American people and communities
throughout the country the bipartisan
budget agreement protects our historic
and hard-earned economic recovery and
all the progress that American workers
have made in the last two years members
of Congress from both parties came
together to prevent a catastrophic
default and demonstrated once more that
America is a nation that pays its bills
and meets its obligations and will
always be
it is a testament to the president's
strength that more Democrats than
Republicans in both house of Congress
voted for this bill
the work is far from Finnish but this
bipartisan agreement is a reminder of
what's possible when we act in the best
interest of our country
now yesterday as you all know marked the
first day of pride month the Biden
Harris Administration joins America's
across Americans across the country to
celebrate the strength resilience and
bravery of the lgbtqi plus community and
we affirm our commitment to fight for
equality and freedom for all people
the reality is this year has been really
scary for our community people are being
treated frightened intimidated
and targeted for who they are and who
they love this year alone more than 600
anti-lgbtqi bills have been filed in
state houses across the country and a
significant portion of those bills
Target transgender youth as President
Biden says these young people are some
of the bravest people he knows but no
one should have to be brave to be
themselves
it's why the president has taken
historic steps to advance equality for
lgbtqia community and protect civil
rights
he was proud to sign an executive order
directing federal agencies to protect
lgbtqi families and youth support youth
mental health and stop harmful
conversion therapy policies
doj is actively supporting challenges to
state laws that Target transgender kids
in light of the Dobbs decision he took
action to protect marriage equality by
signing into law the respect for
Marriage Act
and he continues to call on Congress to
pass the equality act to enshrine civil
rights protections for lgbtqi plus
Americans in federal law on behalf of
the administration I will say to the
lgbtq plus community that we see you we
love you and we will continue to
celebrate you not just this month but
every month
we're going to continue to stand
alongside you and fight back against
these attacks and we're going to remain
focused on advancing equality for all
people across the country
now today as you all know as well we're
also marking National Gun Violence
awareness day and in recognition the
White House will be lit in Orange lights
this evening and many of us are wearing
orange as you can see from what I'm
wearing today all orange as we remember
the thousands of Americans killed and
injured an acts of gun violence across
our nation
as some of you may know this observance
started a decade ago after a 15 year old
girl named had hadiya Pendleton was shot
and killed
on a playground in Chicago just one week
after Marching In President Obama's
second inaugural parade soon after the
strategy hadiya's friends commemorated
her life by wearing orange they chose
this color because it's what Hunters
wear in the woods to protect themselves
from others
wear orange is now observed every June
as the president said this morning in
his statement he's proud to have signed
the most significant gun safety
legislation in decades and dozens of
executive actions but as we all know it
is nearly not enough it will take
congressional action to make the kinds
of meaningful reforms we need to keep
our communities safe like kids like
hadiya
today vice president Harris will also
deliver remarks at John Lewis High
School where she will talk about the
administration administration's actions
to reduce gun violence and call on young
people to continue leaving efforts to
end gun violence and save lives today
and every day the president and the
first lady are praying for the victims
of gun violence Across America and for
the survivors who will carry trauma for
the rest of their lives and the
president continues to call on Congress
to act on Common Sense reforms that will
curb our gun violence epidemic like
establishing Universal background checks
requiring safe storage of firearms and
finally Banning assault weapons and high
capacity magazine now finally uh this
weekend just to give you guys a week
ahead of what's going to be happening in
the next couple of days the president
will remain in Washington D.C on Monday
afternoon the president will welcome
prime minister meta Frederickson
Frederickson of Denmark to the White
House to further strengthen the deep and
enduring ties between the United States
and Denmark later the president will
welcome the Kansas City Chiefs to the
White House to celebrate their
Championship season and victory in the
Super Bowl 57. on Tuesday the president
will hold a cabinet meeting the vice
president per usual will participate in
that cabinet meeting as well on Thursday
morning the president will greet prime
minister sunac and Mrs murti of the
United Kingdom of an official working
visit to the to further deepen the
relationship the close and historic
relationship and partnership between the
United States and the United Kingdom
then the president will hold a bilateral
meeting with the prime minister in the
afternoon as I mentioned before the
president will host a joint press
conference with the Prime Minister as
well in the evening
the president will host a Pride
Celebration with Betty Who on the south
lawn Friday evening
the president and the first lady will
travel to Camp David on Sunday the
president and the first lady will return
to the White House from camp Camp David
in the evening the president and the
first lady will host a reception for the
Ford Theater Gala at the White House
finally finally finally on a Bittersweet
note we hope you'll join us today in
saying goodbye to our valued member of
the White House Press team you all know
Hile Haru as the always kind always
smiling press Wrangler who keeps events
running smoothly what you may not know
is that Hile is a lawyer and a business
school graduate who spent the last 10
months of her presidential management
fellow and and here with us as you all
know and as she is has been an
independent indispensable member of our
team we will miss you uh pla we will
miss your kindness and also apparently I
don't didn't know anything about this
but you have brought in Hawaiian snacks
before which I've never tried so I don't
know how I got left out of this but she
brings them to the office and and her
willingness to take on any challenge to
help the White House Press team and the
reporters we work with I know many of
you will join me tonight and for the
goodbye festivities this evening and if
you cannot join us this evening please
come to the lower press and please say
goodbye to our press team member and um
and also our favorite lawyer as well I
think you have something to share with
our friends here in the room you can try
some of these Hawaiian treats that I've
never had to try
or
I think one thing we could be known for
and as this press team is giving a lot
of treats
we love to share you're very welcome
[Laughter]
there you go
oh that's right Nancy Nancy knows
um okay with that let's get going Chris
hello what you got for us so uh
president had the fall yesterday uh the
White House said that he's fine uh was
he checked out by a doctor what was that
I didn't like what was the result so
just want to just remind everybody what
the president uh
was uh in Colorado Springs for yesterday
he was there uh to uh to offer um uh his
thanks to the dedicated Brave women and
men and women who are graduating and and
about to serve in the Air Force and he
was proud very proud to shake the hands
of more than 900 of them at beforehand
so I just want to make sure that we are
aware as commander-in-chief that is why
he was there and he was incredibly proud
to do so uh and just to just you know
make sure we clear the record here he
tripped over a sandbag on the stage and
briefly he tripped and got up and he he
got got right back up and continued
continued what he was there to do
he did not uh he there was no need for
the doctor to see him as it was related
to the fall and he's doing fine you saw
most of some of you saw him last night
when he returned uh getting off of
marine one on the south lawn he spoke to
this uh so I would refer you back to his
comments and so I'll just leave it there
I trust a lot of confidence
that NATO what is the source of his
confidence and bite himself with erwan
earlier this week I was her Assurance
given there if they made it more
confident so I'm not going to go into
private discussions or conversation that
he had uh with uh with erdogan I
mentioned a couple days ago that the
president did bring up Sweden and NATO
and so the president continues to be
confident uh and uh and he's uh
hopefully uh we hope that this will
definitely occur that we'll see Sweden
be part of the NATO alliance
evidence remarks tonight in the
meals what's behind that decision to do
it tonight and in that setting so just a
little bit
um well one of the things I can say why
why the Oval Office why tonight as you
all know we've been talking about
averting a catastrophic default for the
past a couple of weeks the past couple
of months and how is important months
and how important it was for the
president to do that there is a gravity
as you all can imagine of this moment
and so the president wanted to make sure
that he addressed the American people
directly and he's going to be speaking
clearly from the Oval Office behind the
Resolute desk to the American people for
the first time and so during a prime
time clearly at seven o'clock doing
Prime Time hour and so he just wanted to
make sure that the American people
understood how important it was to get
this done how important it was to do
this in a bipartisan way this would have
been a first ever default we've listed
out what could have happened we created
a recession potentially triggered a
recession lose millions of jobs up to
eight million jobs increased costs for
all Americans when we're talking about
retirement accounts and devastating
paychecks that's what could have
happened by Monday if we didn't get this
done caused chaos and Cat and
catastrophe in the world economy and
undermine the full faith and credit of
of the United States that's what was
able to avert it in a bipartisan way and
so the president wants to lay that out
for the American people and that's what
you're going to hear them do today which
is now warning that the U.S credit
rating is still though at risk once this
deal is done how confident are you that
how confident are you that a downgrade
will be avoided so look as I as we all
saw we saw a bipartisan agenda come
together in a way that the in a way that
Congress should work right and it was uh
it was majority we saw a majority of
bipartisanship from both chambers of
Congress passed a strong a strong fiscal
responsibility proposal that will reduce
the deficit by more than a trillion
dollars that is important to note and it
ensures that the government will
continue to meet our commit commitments
which is important to do as well so uh
look the treasury market Remains the
safest the deepest and the most liquid
Market in the world and so I'll just
leave it there as what we would do by
basically laying out what we've been
able to do and I think that's important
for the world to see just any updates on
when he'll actually sign the bill at
this point so uh it won't be today the
the house and the Senate have to do
their business and so we're going to
work very quickly with them to get this
done to make sure we can sign it
hopefully as soon as as soon as tomorrow
but we have to let the house and the
Senate do what they need to do so they
can get to us so the president can sign
it
um fish in their statement today said
that the repeated political stand-ups is
what was lowering their confidence in
the president's speech today will he lay
out any kind of plan to avoid this stand
up going forward and could he
potentially address the use of the 14th
Amendment so look I'm not going to
certainly get ahead of what the
president will say today as a for as it
relates to the 14th Amendment the
president has spoken to that numerous of
times what was important for him is to
get this was to get this deal done and
to take uh default off the table which
is what we saw happen uh these past
couple of days look um the president
wants to make sure that the American
people understand and understood what
occurred Congress came together
the leaders came together to agree on a
bipartisan bipartisan budget agreement
that protects our the economic progress
that we made and that will protect to
protect not the just not just the
economy but also the American people and
so look when we think about the
investing of in America what the
president proposed those historic pieces
of legislation those were protected the
chips and science act the bipartisan
infrastructure law think about the
veterans that the uh The Pact act you
think about all those important pieces
of legislation that's going to make sure
that we continue to grow economy from
the bottom up the middle out those are
the things that the president was able
to protect Social Security Medicare
Medicaid and so all of these things are
incredibly important and he's going to
lay that out and I'm just not going to
get ahead of him too much
and then last night you guys put out a
readout of a call with President Obama
where you said they discussed this that
deal but also other topics what were
some of the other topics they discussed
and why did you decide to read out this
call I mean my understanding was that
they spoke you know somewhat regularly
today yeah they speak regularly as we
know there was the debt limit situation
that was occurring and so I think it was
important uh for us to uh for us to read
it out to let them know that the
president President Obama and President
Biden spoke no particular no specific
particular reasoning but just in the
moment we wanted to read out this
conversation that they had and I know
sometimes people ask when they speak and
we thought because of the debt limit
because of the bipartisanship that we
saw happening in the last couple of days
it was important to also lay out that
the president President Obama and
President Biden spoke other topics not
going to get into it um from here I'm
sure we will be we will hear more on
what those other topics are you know the
president President Obama has been here
a couple times but I just don't have
anything else to lay out specifically
okay Joey yeah thanks Korey uh is the
president concerned uh with the
precedent that this debt ceiling
standoff that we're coming out of sets
perhaps in terms of how a party uh
Republicans in this case not in the
White House might try to pass uh
policies past their objectives
priorities in the future
meaning we'll say that one more time
yeah I mean does this is he concerned
that this sets a precedent in terms of
how Republicans might try to uh enact
pass policies down the road during the
next time we get to a debt ceiling maxed
out I mean look I think that the fact
that this is a president that was able
to bring both sides together and get
this done on behalf of the American
people I think that's important I think
that's what we're going to point to I
can't speak to what republicans in
Congress are going to do and might not
do or get into hypotheticals I think
what's important here is that we avoided
averted something that could have been
incredibly catastrophic to our economy
and hurt American families and so that's
going to be our Focus you know not going
to get into hypotheticals from here but
I think that what you have seen what
you've all been reporting and seen the
past two weeks people didn't think would
happen right people didn't have the
confidence that the president would
bring both sides together to make this
happen and it did and so that's
important on behalf of the American
people the American people one here and
I think that's important to speak to you
prime minister Monday
what does the president think of her and
would he consider
well there's a reason I asked him okay
which is um is he thinking of asking her
to stand for NATO General Secretary
General so um look I could say that the
two leaders have a broad agenda that
they will discuss on Monday they will
review our efforts as NATO allies and
close Partners to strengthen
transatlantic security and bolster
economic Prosperity they will discuss
our unwavering support for Ukraine in
the face of Russia's brutal war of
regression and I expect our joint
efforts and to train Ukraine Ukrainian
pilots on the fourth generation aircraft
including f-16s will be part of that
conversations and so they're going to
coordinate on a range of issues whether
it's climate change energy security
Global issues and so he's looking
forward the president I can say is
looking forward to his conversation with
her they had a good conversation when
they met NATO Summit in Madrid I'm sorry
last year in Ladle summer in Madrid and
so he's looking forward to continuing
those type of that conversation I'm just
not going to get ahead of anything
specifics clearly we'll have a you all
there will be a bilap you'll have an
opportunity to uh to see their
relationship up close and we'll probably
have a readout once they have once
they're done with their uh their
extended bilateral speculation that she
might be in line for the next
NATO Secretary General we're just not
going to get into any speculation as far
as that let me ask you as well about
this weekend's OPEC meeting does the
White House have any expectation or any
signal or desire for what may come out
of that so as you know we're not we're
not members of the OPEC OPEC plus I'm
not going to get into what conversation
or what may come out of that
um and so I'm just going to leave it
there and see and we'll we'll see what
comes out of those discussions let's
follow up on the earlier question about
his remarks tonight can you can you
explain more as to why you chose the
oval look he chose the oval because this
was a uh really the gravity of the
situation of what could have happened uh
you know if we indeed averted didn't
avert I should say uh uh or the you know
defaulting could have been catastrophic
could have been catastrophic and so he
wanted to talk directly to the American
people about what we have been able to
do in a bipartisan way with his
leadership coming up with a budget
agreement that's going to cut the
deficit as I just explained moments ago
by a trillion dollars but also saved
some important programs that Americans
need just just some basic basic things
that Americans need every day and so we
think about health care we think about
social security Medicare Medicaid all
these things were certainly uh potential
for uh for being cut 21 million 21
million million people losing health
care that matters and so the president
wanted to wants to lay that out wants to
talk directly to the American people and
talk about how we were able to come
together and deliver up for uh for
American families that's important we
think that's important so he's going to
use uh you know his uh first oval oval
address to talk directly to them
hey thanks Karina I wanted to drill a
little bit further on the display of
bipartisanship you talked about the two
related questions has
um the president talked to speaker
McCarthy since legislation passed or
extended an offer for him to come to the
White House or to the oval or so don't
have a conversation Beyond uh what we
laid out a couple days ago after the
house uh at the house uh passed the
their version of the bill the president
certainly spoke to speaker McCarthy
after that after that passage they've
spoken they've met about three times in
the past uh in the in the last month
he's spoken several times and as you saw
on Monday the president thanked speaker
McCarthy for coming together and having
this uh for coming together and having
this bipartisan agreement don't have
more to share as the speaker clearly
they will be talking and meeting a lot
more on different on different
legislative agendas and issues but I
just don't have anything else to share
and on that I I wonder if
people can glean from this that there's
a that you guys have more of a template
for how to deal with the speaker and in
an era of divided government with these
negotiations ultimately coming up
successful I mean look I think what you
saw in display in full display the last
couple of weeks and look maybe there's a
template maybe there isn't but when I
can't say for sure right is that you had
leadership in congress the president
come together and lay out in a divided
government as you just laid out go
through a negotiation process as we have
said before negotiations are hard not
everybody gets what they uh what they
want all that they want and they came
together to deliver for the American
people so I can't speak to a template
for future conversations but what I can
say is this is a president as Senator as
as a vice president and now as president
believes in bipartisanship many people
said he couldn't do it when he talked
about it during his inaugural address
right before stepping into the role and
he was able to do that he was able to
continue the bipartisan that we have
seen on historic legislation and now on
averting a a something that would have
been catastrophic to our economy
going back to Fitch and their continued
negative one
um has the White House or treasury or
anyone else been in touch with Fitch and
the other ratings agencies even after a
deal coming together and are you
concerned that a downgrade could still
happen uh the s p downgrade happened in
2011 after there was a deal so look I
don't have any conversations to lay out
or to speak to uh with any of the uh you
know specific agencies what I can lay
out and talk speak to is this
bipartisanship that we saw uh it from
both both Chambers which is important
right we saw both Chambers come together
and deliver here because of the
president's leadership and the deficit
it's going to lower the deficit by one
trillion dollars that's what I can speak
to again the treasury market remains
safest deepest and most liquid Market in
the world and I think that's important I
cannot speak to what agencies are going
to be doing what I can speak to is what
we've been able to do from here and I
think that's what's important here
during the most frenzy part of the
negotiation some Hill Democrats were
frustrated that Kevin McCarthy was going
out into the hallways and talking to
reporters constantly Non-Stop and and
that he was sort of controlling the
narrative
um while the White House and the
president especially were pretty quiet
publicly
um is this Oval Office address the
president getting the last word look the
president is the president
and the American people look to him for
deliver on their on their behalf
and when you think about what could have
happened what could have happened here
if we did not pay our bills right if we
did not get this done if we did not
avert a default that would have been
catastrophic we think about millions of
jobs being lost we think about people's
retirement accounts you know you think
about what could have happened here to
our seniors to our veterans to American
families across the country on programs
that they truly truly need uh you know
that is something that the president
believes he should speak to that is
something that the president believes
that he has an opportunity to talk
directly to the American people this was
this was this could have been as we've
said over and over again as you all
reported it could have been devastating
devastating to our economy devastating
to American families this is we believe
he believes is a good moment to lay that
out and to talk to the American people
and how we were able to come together to
avert this crisis potential crisis okay
speak to whether you're confident that
it will be signed in time for treasury
to do
to do to avoid running out of class they
said as soon as Monday okay if you're
saying a signing as soon as tomorrow
which raises the prospect of signing
Sunday is is it good are you good on
this we feel confident we we feel
confident we are not nervous we feel
confident that it could be signed as
soon as tomorrow house and the Senate
clearly have to do their business and
get it and getting the the bill to us as
far as any specifics as what treasury
needs to do I would certainly refer you
to them but we're going to get this done
certainly before June 5th
the downgrade question if I'm hearing
what you're saying you don't know
whether you'll be downgraded again or
not you don't believe that should happen
look it's not it's not something that uh
clearly that uh I can speak to right
that is up to uh clearly that is a
response that's going to come from the
agencies what I can say is what we've
been able to do in a bipartisan way
dealing with the deficit right making
sure that the best deficit uh uh is will
be addressed reduced by more than a
trillion dollars I think that's really
important we believe that it is a
fiscally responsible piece of
legislation that the bipartisan
legislation that was agreed upon and
that really is is important we will
continue to meet our commitments that's
important so I can speak to what we were
able to do I cannot speak to the
agencies uh and uh and I'll just leave
it there
the president want to explore ways to
eliminate the debt ceiling he's sort of
amused about whether the board game
could be used or not before will the
head ceiling still be there in 2025 when
we come back so look um the president
has uh has commented on this uh he
believed that is something for Congress
to kind of deal with he's I'm just not
going to go beyond what the president
has laid out and said about the
particularly about the polishing
I would ask you if I can very quickly
about one of the items included in the
debt limit
um deals soon to become law where uh
Senator Tim Kaine in Virginia said that
he wasn't alerted about the Mountain
Valley pipeline as you know that cuts it
goes from West Virginia cuts through
parts of his State here Tim Kaine said
the White House doesn't even bother to
pick up the phone and call me as the
president now spoken to Tim Kaine and if
not why not I don't have any uh any
conversations to read out uh what I can
say that we've been very clear and
consistent for months that the president
supported right Senator manchin's
permitting bill which included this
project that is not new that has been
something that we've been pretty
consistent about saying you've heard me
say multiple times at the podium that
there's nothing new here as it relates
to this particular project again we've
been consistent there's nothing new
we've known for some time uh look and
we've also said we may not love
everything in the bill but we support it
and we have repeatedly called on
Congress to pass it ever since we
secured the inflation reduction act so
um look we believe that the bipartisan
budget
deal here that was reached is something
that that we all should be proud of that
Congressional democrats should be proud
of and it really protected it protected
some some of all of the president's
historical uh historical legislation but
particularly on climate legislation as
well and I think that's important moving
it's going to move forward the
environmental justice projects and
that's important as well accelerate our
climate agenda which is one of the four
crises that the president talked about
when he walked into this Administration
and so look that's uh that's what I can
lay out for you I just don't have any
conversations to read out as far as it
relates to Senator Kane who we respect
and have had a very good relationship
with over the past two years all
Democrats aren't celebrating there's
still five Democrats and at least in the
Senate who voted against it progressives
so what does the White House say to
those progressives and what does the
White House say to combat the criticism
from some Democrats that Republicans
play hardball when it comes to these
negotiations Asians and the Democrats do
not I mean look I'm not going to speak
to how any of our Democratic friends
voted on this that is a decision that
they make on their own what I can speak
to is how we believe this bipartisan
agreement that's soon to be law uh
really is going to make sure that we
protect some of the most important
programs for American families and that
matters well you said Progressive
Americans though obviously the president
represents all Americans but certainly
Progressive Democrats are a part of the
base of support he needs to be reelected
what do you say to those Americans who
are disillusioned by this look this is a
president if you look at his his his
record the last two years it has been
historic it has been one of the most
historical historic legislative
legislative accomplishments that we have
seen from a president and that matters
when you talk about a president who
wants to build an economy from the
bottom up middle out that's what we've
seen we talk about inflation reduction
act it's going to lower health care
costs it's going to lower energy costs
you talk about bipartisan infrastructure
legislation it's going to actually
invest in those very communities to make
sure that we have we have an
infrastructure whether it's Broadband
whether it's tunnels and bridges to make
sure that we don't leave anybody behind
creating creating jobs I just laid out
what the jobs numbers was this for this
this month and how we've the president
under his watch 13. 13 more than 13
million jobs have been created under
this president that matters that is a
president that cares about all Americans
that make sure that no one is Left
Behind and that there's Equity at the
center of everything that we've done and
so look Americans reacted to this in the
midterms in 2022 saying they approved of
what we were able to do and so that
matters as well and so look and every
piece of legislation that he's moved
forward that have been historic have
been incredibly popular so this clearly
this is a president that cares about all
Americans and is always zero focused on
and the American people are going to
hear directly from him this evening
can't Stephen thanks green the present
crisis disaster averted the country at a
certain point is going to have to
Grapple with the substantially more
significant question of how the
government's going to meet the
obligations and it's made to Social
Security recipients Medicare recipients
over the next decade and more so should
we expect the president to reflect on
that challenge tonight and how does he
view the congress's ability to Grapple
with those questions in the way for this
bipartisan it's a good question Steve
and clearly there's more work to be done
we've never said after this agreement
the work is done we've never said that
clearly there's more work to be done I'm
not going to get ahead of what the
president's going to say specifically
this evening but I would say tune in and
you'll hear directly from him
okay
Karina the Republicans were able to pass
a bill in the Senate that overturned
president student loan plan what does it
say that that Democrats such as John
tester and Joe manchin supported
overturning that bill and do you have a
timetable on MovieTube so um again has
to come to us the president clearly is
going to veto this bill what I can say
is uh
um I think what's important here
um is I'm not going to speak directly to
uh how members uh Senators voted on this
uh but I will say and I said this a few
times this is uh this is this is when
you think about the students the student
relief program this is going to give
Americans a little bit of breathing room
especially after coming going through
the pandemic you we've said this over
and over again 90 of the relief is going
to go to Americans who make 75 000 or
less that matters this is part of the
president's Economic Policy it's an
economic plan to make sure we do not
leave anybody behind and so uh you know
he's going to continue to fight for
American families and and uh you know if
this Bill gets his desk as I just
mentioned he's going to veto it and so
again it's going to help American
families
is why the president put this forth put
this forth especially after coming
coming getting through the pandemic and
we wanted to make sure that people
didn't default uh when their loan
payments resume which is going to happen
uh next month in August I should be more
clear in August just a couple
Republicans felt that the defense
funding levels were too low and they
sought assurances from both the Senate
above the Democratic Republican leaders
in the Senate that it's possible for a
security funding could be provided is
the president open to additional defense
funding or does he feel like under this
deal that the defense spending is
so look we kept we kept the levels that
the president asked for as you know if
you look at his uh um fiscal year 2024
budget and so that's important the
president felt like he was able to
protect protect that I'm not going to go
into what's you know there's going to be
an Appropriations process as you all
know
director young talked about that when
she was here so certainly not going to
get into that process but look this is
this is a deal a bipartisan agreement a
common sense reasonable bipartisan
agreement and when you negotiate on
these types of agreement not everybody
no one gets everything that they want
and we've been very clear about that and
so look the president's going to talk
later this evening I talked to speak
directly to the American people and
they'll hear from him
okay thank you I wanted to ask one
question about whether or not the
president plans to invite the speaker to
whatever the signing happened is that in
the works uh don't have anything to
share on what the signing is going to
look like we the president clearly wants
to sign the bill as soon as possible is
important as someone just laid out June
5th is on Monday so he wants to get to
it as soon as possible on that question
about sort of the template now for
working in a divided government
speaker approve the same unchanged after
the last several weeks so again the
president thanked the speaker on Monday
I think that was important they came to
an agreement a bipartisan reasonable
agreement I think that's important
they've met met about three times in the
past month they've talked several times
certainly not going to get into uh the
president's relationship with McCarthy
but clearly they were able to deliver on
behalf of the American people we've got
a strong bipartisan votes in both the
house and the Senate to get this done
very quickly it is Friday and it is done
right they got it done just last night
and the president's going to speak to
the American people directly to talk
about uh What uh what occurred the last
couple of weeks the last couple of
months and I think that's is what is
important here
thank you
um so when the president of Japan is
pricked up when he spoke about Paul or
maybe a possible coming fall with China
before Oh say that one more time
yeah my accent oh yeah
which is what we heard a lot yesterday
um I thought I feel like I'm gonna want
to python sketch it
okay
so there's a lot Happening Here folks
it's Friday it's Friday I have a
follow-up
s there we are the president
and
um we've since learned today we learned
that um CIA director was in China
sometime before this um brief mention of
the word I won't repeat in Japan
um is that are those two things
connected did the director come back
with some news that might make the
president think about a fall so as
as a relief
as it relates to the CIA directors
travel I would have to refer you to to
the CIA directly to speak to that I just
don't I'm not going to get into it from
here from the podium so I would have to
refer you to the CIA how about uh how
about any um I know you're going to tell
me you've got nothing to share but I
haven't about a phone called president
XI well look the president uh uh is
looking forward to uh president speaking
to president XI as you know they've
spoken many times in the last two years
uh just don't have anything to read out
when the the time is appropriate
certainly that conversation will occur
oh okay that's great um the debt
negotiation have been such a big focus
on the agenda for the last couple of
weeks what's the next top legislative
priority that the president wants
Congress to move forward on so that's a
good question I talked about the uh
equality act right uh for at the
beginning here is something that the
president really wants to see move
forward and is an important agenda that
he believes that needs to happen he's
talked about that many times so nothing
new there uh and so look the president
has had a remarkable record as it
relates to getting things done in a
bipartisan way I've talked about the
historic pieces of legislation that he's
been able to make happen in a and it's
it's a record because we have not seen
anything like that from from any
Administration think about the chips and
science act you think about the the
veterans uh program the ACT there for
veterans program we think about the
infrastructure legislation as well which
is clearly law now so um look
we also worked with Congress to prevent
uh this this default and so uh there's
the equality act there's permitting
reform uh there's Roe v Wade there's
comprehensive immigration reform there's
the pro act or reducing the deficit by
making the rich pay their share fair
share so the president has a serious
agenda that he wants to get done for the
American people and he's going to
continue to uh to work on that agenda
and not only that his agenda is actually
popular with majority of Americans so
this is all of uh this isn't this is
important to him uh he'll stay focused
on getting these things done not you
know all those things that you just
mentioned
um are things the president would like
to do there's been a lot of talk about
you know with the divided government not
everybody can get everything they want
with this latest negotiation given the
lessons learned from all of this what
are the policies that the administration
thinks could get bipartisan support
given what you guys just went through
with this thing look it's a good
question I think what I we can say is as
I just laid out all of these different
uh issues uh and pieces of legislation
that's important those are
popular majority of Americans want to
see these things done and so I think
that matters that's how the president's
going to move forward those are the
conversations that we're going to
continue to have with uh with members of
Congress how do we get these things done
we hear us talk about gun safety and I
know that's a tough issue but we can't
continue to see our kids and and
communities being killed you know we
talk about the Roe v Wade and really
making that the law of the land we have
to make sure that we protect the
freedoms the freedoms of American of
women in particular as it relates to
women's Reproductive Rights equality act
all of those things are popular all of
those things are things that the
American people want to see and so look
it's not going to be easy it's never
easy the president has always understood
that and people have always I have also
said many folks have said he couldn't
get it done and every challenge he's
been able to get it done it might take a
little bit more time a little longer but
we believe that these are things are
important or critical that American
families want to see happen and so it's
not going to stop us because there's a
divided government again we were just
able to get this done in a bipartisan
way
as the president is celebrating this
bipartisan win on the debt deal he is
squashing the bipartisan bill on student
loans why does he accept the will of the
people in one area but ignore the will
of the people when it seeks to block the
transfer of this debt to the taxpayers
I don't think protecting American
families or making sure that we give
them a little bit of a breathing room is
going against the will of the American
people when you think about 90 percent
right when you think about his plan and
how it's going to help 90 percent of
Americans who make seventy five thousand
dollars or less that's what we talk
about that's the most important thing to
remember about the student loan it's
going to help people who truly truly
really need it in a time where the loan
as you know the pause is going to lift
we don't we want to make sure that the
people people have a little bit of extra
extra breathing room to be able to pay
for those loans once the pause is lifted
in August and so that matters I don't
think I don't think and also his plan is
actually very popular with Americans
process wise I mean his forgiveness plan
was done by executive order even the
payment pause was done through an
emergency statute but the debt bill that
mandates restarting payments got votes
in Congress to pass this bill you know
rejecting the forgiveness program
cleared both Chambers and is heading to
the president's desk how how do you
argue with that that it this is clearly
what people want to see happen so look
you're talking about death relief that
would have been that would have made 40
million people eligible who are
borrowers 40 million people
again most of whom are making less than
75 000 a year that's who the president
is focused on that's who the president
wants to make sure he protects and
that's what he did
and look we also preserved our ability
to pause student loan payments should be
necessary in an event of future
emergencies that's also important right
we have to look to see what hap we don't
know what's going to happen in the
future so we have to make sure we're
ready for that and so when you think
about 40 million Americans who are bars
protecting them protecting folks 90 who
make 75 000 less I think that's
important for the president to be to
protect uh to protect the student loan
relief plan right as he did during these
budget negotiations and he's going to
veto this resolution that as you just
stated that it has passed because it is
not the right thing to do the president
is always going to focus on American
families he's always going to focus on
the Americans who need it the most at
this time again 90 from his plan ninety
percent of folks who are borrowers are
making 75 000 Less in this plan who
makes 75 000 or less on in this plant is
going to be protected that matters and
it's a popular plan as well
um should someone who's a drug user be
able to possess a firearm I'm not going
to get into the Tit for Tat on this I'm
I'm just not going to go ahead green
um I should talk about next steps
following up on Karen's questions and
answer with you
Supreme Court
there are two issues that deal with
quality Equity inclusion voting rights
Democrats are still pushing for that
screaming the gerrymandering right now
in this nation is very unfair of their
constituents and also the issue of
the admissions affirmative action
Admissions and colleges
what are you bracing for or what are you
planning for the recent weeks to come so
look that's something that the
Department of Justice certainly is
keeping an eye on they will they have
been focused on that issue certainly not
going to speak to what they're bracing
for or potentially thinking might may
happen but they are dealing with this or
I would refer you to the Department of
Justice look when it comes to equity
when it comes to racial Equity when the
president walked into this
Administration he talked about I
mentioned this moments ago about the
four crises that we needed to deal with
racial Equity was one of them and that's
why this president has taken steps so
it's almost day one to make sure that
federal government every agency in
particular he signed an executive order
making sure that there was racial Equity
coming out of the agencies and as it
relates to voting rights he's been very
clear about where he stands on that and
making sure that we deal with that in a
real way making sure that there is
legislation that that uh calling on
Congress to put forth the legislation
that deals with voting rights and so
look the president has been very clear
the vice president has been very clear
there are real issues that we need to
take uh to take address and to look at
and he's been able to deal with that
deal with those issues deals with Racial
equality equality from the federal
government but clearly there's more work
to be done
Democrats are very uh intent on trying
to push forward voting rights nothing
happened in the house but it could
definitely have in the Senate are you
expecting the president to possibly lean
in this time on this next wave of a push
for new voting rights laws I mean look
the president has always been clear of
where he stands on the voting rights law
and that it needs to happen and he's
always supported that and he's going to
continue to do to do so he you know
commends Congress to uh to continue to
find a path forward as they should we
have to deal with this this is a real
issue that we have to deal with
you mentioned the historically low
unemployment low uh four percent for
such a long time but unemployment did
jump last month by a fairly surprising
margin from 3.4 to 3.7 the White House
have a view on why that might be and why
um unemployment among black workers
jumped by almost a full percentage point
so uh it's a bit complicated I've asked
The Economist about this here uh and uh
but those numbers come from different
surveys so that's important to note the
number of jobs created is from a
business survey that that came out but
the unemployment rate is from a survey
of households our economic experts think
they moved in a different direction this
month mainly because of the way they
were categorized that jobs were
categorized specifically self
self-employment but we We Believe As I
said at the top regardless of the number
when you think about 3.7 that's the jump
from 3.4 to 3.7 unemployment and More
Than 3 hundred thousand jobs created
just this last month is a sign of very
strong labor market and the resilient
economy so it's important to actually
put those two together and see how we
see the trajectory as we as we look at
the economy continuing uh to continue to
grow and you do you does the White House
believe that the fact that
jobs continue to grow every month at a
faster rate than economists are
predicting is a sign that the economy is
still overheated and that the FED may
have to raise interest rates again so
look we're not going to speak to we've
been very very consistent here about not
speaking to the uh the fed and its
policy so we'll continue to do so and
look you know we continue to believe
that we are in a transition to more
stable and steady growth that's what we
have been seeing and beating certainly
beating inflation Remains the
president's top economic goal it's a
priority and but we have seen some
progress over the last 10 months now
annual inflation has fallen and it's
down by 40 percent just last last summer
so all of these things are clearly
important not going to speak to the FED
policies we'll let them do their
business independently and that's
something that we believe that this
President is incredibly important for
for that to happen and occur
um I'll take one last question okay
thank you so NATO members are still very
divided about on your Korean membership
the United States supporting for NATO
membership for Ukraine so look we've
said this over and over again when it
comes to Nato we believe and it's uh we
are committed to the open door policy uh
any Alliance decision is is between the
31 allies and the uh and the aspirant
country we've said that many times
before that has not changed has been our
view and so but right now as we've said
many times my NSC colleagues have said
many times the president has said many
times we're focused on what we can do to
support Ukraine's effort to fight for
their democracy uh clearly to fight for
their freedom against the Russia
Russia's aggression and that's what
we're going to continue to do we just
announced 300 million dollars of
additional assistance just a couple days
ago and so you've seen that commitment
over the past 15 months and we'll
continue that thank you everybody have a
great weekend
foreign